[Musique]
la semaine dernière c'était les
inondations en avril le verglas les
phénomènes météorologiques extrêmes sont
de plus en plus fréquents et les
dommages qui laissent dans leur siège de
plus en plus importants les
municipalités québécoises doivent donc
s'adapter de coûteux travaux quels sont
incapables de payer seul le nouveau
président de l'Union des municipalités
du Québec Martin danfosse a demandé
l'aide du gouvernement logo or la
réponse est loin d'être satisfaisante
il faut un moment donné être capable
tout le monde de comprendre que il y a
pas de miracle
puis oui c'est le fan de parler
diversification c'est le fond de parler
des rééquilibrage mais faut comprendre
que nous aussi on a nos défis qu'on n'a
pas de marge de manœuvre
Martin nouveau président de l'UQ bonjour
Félicitations merci Monsieur parlons
dans l'air du temps restons dans l'air
du temps les inondations qu'on a vu les
images épouvantables qu'on a vu un peu
partout au Québec cette semaine
c'est un problème pour plusieurs
municipalités je suis persuadé qu'on en
parle sur le parquet de de des assises
de l'UMP
le Premier ministre a déjà dit il n'y a
pas davantage d'argent on fait quoi
quand on est devant un discours comme ça
la réalité c'est que on a juste pas le
choix il y a une grande différence dans
le discours du premier ministre puis
c'est intéressant parce que vous allez
vous rappeler que le pacte vert a été
déposé le 13 septembre par l'Union des
municipalités du Québec juste avant les
élections on s'est fait fermer la porte
rapidement mais on sent une évolution
dans le discours parce que pour plus
tard que en fait il y a quelques jours
quelques semaines à peine il
reconnaissait clairement et c'était
unanime il faut s'adapter au changement
climatique on a eu le verglas puis là la
récurrence des inondations puis on a
juste pas le choix parce que le rapport
d'uranos et WSP est clair l'argent qu'on
investit pas aujourd'hui va nous coûter
à peu près 15 fois plus cher pour
corriger ce qui se passe mais maintenant
il y a personne le fédéral dit on a des
sous mon travail avec les provinces les
provinces dit on a de l'argent mais
c'est limité les villes disent on des
taxes foncières mais on peut pas aller
au-delà d'une certaine on apprend où
l'argent pour s'adapter mais vous avez
raison que c'est un enjeu de
priorisation en fait on a des choix à
faire le gouvernement des choix à faire
nous le milieu municipal quand on fait
des choix budgétaires ben ça fait partie
la partie à partir du moment où avarenne
prenons juste l'exemple je perds depuis
5 ans un mètre dans mon parc qu'il
fleuron vers&nois d'érosion des berges
mais là je réoriente des priorités
budgétaires c'est pas de la nouvelle
argent c'est des choix qu'on doit
ramener
on a dû endiguer parce que j'allais
perdre ma piste cyclable donc on
comprend que ça ce phénomène-là est pas
unique c'est partout là on a maintenant
des tornades on a les chaleurs extrêmes
on n'a jamais vécu ça avant enfin que
tout le monde prend conscience ok il se
passe quelque chose donc faut intervenir
puis c'est surtout de rendre nos
infrastructures plus résiliantes mais
c'est un chantier qui est important on
veut le faire avec le gouvernement
supérieur mais faut travailler en équipe
mais monsieur Legault la semaine
dernière a dit ben vous avez des taxes
foncières vous pouvez vous pouvez les
augmenter vous avez de la marge de
manœuvre si on compare ce que le Québec
comme niveau taxe foncière en moyenne
avec d'autres provinces Ontario
nommément vous avez vous avez de
l'espace vous dites quoi
j'ai le goût de vous dire serait
peut-être été bien qu'il ne baisse pas
les impôts pour se servir de ces argents
là pour répondre aux besoins de la
population parce que les changements
climatiques là prenons juste la région
de Gatineau quand des centaines de
sous-sols sont inondés puis que les gens
c'est une perte incroyable ces gens-là
se retournent tout le temps vers le
milieu municipal vers le gouvernement de
proximité parce que la réalité c'est que
les élus provinciaux fédéraux vont faire
un tour on les voit après quitte nous on
est sur le terrain tout le temps quelle
est la part de responsabilité des villes
lorsque vous l'avez vous l'avez aménagé
votre territoire vous avez décidé de
l'endroit où serait situé les
infrastructures édifices est-ce que vous
avez une part de responsabilité là
assurément qu'il y en a une par contre
personne ne pouvait prédire un
rehaussement de l'eau avec la fonte des
glaciers c'est ce phénomène qui est
récent donc quand on prévoit un
développement à domicilié on suit sur
les cartes qui nous disent non non il y
a jamais eu d'eau là depuis très
longtemps mais là le climat change donc
ça fait en sorte que ce qu'on l'avait
probablement planifié avant mais faut le
faire différemment mais on peut aussi
construire des bâtiments plus résiliens
il y a des façons de faire où on peut
s'assurer de jamais être inondé tout en
ayant le bâti à la même place mais c'est
tout ça qu'il faut revoir il y a une
part de responsabilité partagée mais là
arrêtons de définir qui est responsable
travailler en équipe pour mettre en
place des solutions rapidement vous êtes
le nouveau président de l'Union des
municipalités du Québec
organisation des priorités évidemment
est-ce que est-ce que la gestion des
changements climatiques c'est la
priorité est-ce que quels sont vos
priorités à l'heure actuelle en fait
c'est la priorité du jour mais il est
clair que dans les priorités très
claires on a un renouvellement du pacte
fiscal qui est prévu à la fin de l'année
2024 puis dans des conditions
vous le savez c'était entre autres la
progression du point de TVQ on voulait
s'assurer qu'il soit intégré dans une
loi Monsieur le Premier Ministre madame
la ministre l'ont confirmé salsera sur
une bonne nouvelle pour nous on parle
des enlieux de taxes il y a eu une
progression au niveau du provincial
parce que la taxation de nos écoles il
paye en partie mais nous on offre des
services les égouts laqueduc tout ça
pourquoi ils auraient un crédit il y a
pas de raison donc ça ce sont des
conditions de base mais après on se
cachera pas que le logement vous
n'entendez parler depuis des lunes ça
nous prend les données là nous disent
que ça nous prend 75000 logements de
plus par année pour assurer une
abordabilité qu'est-ce qui vous faut
pour en arriver à ce type de 75000
logements logements supplémentaire pour
pour parrainer pour préserver l'accès
une chose est sûre tout le monde
reconnaît qui existe plusieurs
programmes au niveau provincial fédéral
mais ils sont tellement complexes donc
ça prend un accès facilitant à ces
programmes-là le délai est tellement
long et là quand le délai vient
incroyablement l'eau on se retrouve avec
le coup de construction n'est plus le
même depuis la demande d'iOS 5 ans que
toujours pas été entériné le modèle
économique fonctionne plus pour
commencer donc honnêtement là il y a une
usure de la part du milieu municipal le
gouvernement reconnaît qu'il faut
trouver une formule plus facilitante
mais ça c'est un frein important donc
c'est la lourdeur de l'appareil
administratif qui vous cause d'énormes
problèmes c'est ça que ça soit dans le
logement que ça soit en environnement
que ça soit au MTQ les programmes sont
trop complexes ça prend plus de
flexibilité je vous entends sur et on en
a parlé à l'émission de la semaine
dernière les
l'intimidation à l'égard des élus
municipaux Québec a lancé une campagne
là-dessus on sait que c'est un problème
dans toutes les sphères politiques
fédérales provinciales municipales c'est
pire ou municipal j'en ai la certitude
on est un gouvernement de proximité on
côtoie nos citoyens quotidiennement
quand tu as des enjeux qui fonctionnent
pas le pas dans ma cour honnêtement on
le reçoit mais pire que ça monsieur
Thibault je suis mère depuis 14 ans moi
j'ai vu en seulement 14 ans l'évolution
fulgurante de l'agression violente
médias sociaux j'ai la certitude que ce
qu'on lit jamais ces gens-là
oseraient venir nous dire ça en plein
visage jamais mais ça honnêtement ça
peut décourager des élus puis ce qui est
triste c'est que ce qu'on observe c'est
que l'agression est pire chez nos élus
féminines ce n'est pas acceptable
certaines infos merci infiniment fait
plaisir